et maintenant jaquette gaspard au
secours elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
alors parmi nous ce soir un philosophe
ce qui m'a inspiré un constat assez
profond quand on voit la situation en
grèce on se dit que c'est normal que ce
soit le pays qui a inventé la philo
ben oui quand on n'a pas les moyens de
s'en sortir autant avoir les outils pour
relativiser son échec
qu'est ce que la philo le christianisme
des athées est ce par proust humoriste
haut de gamme ont passé la suivante la
fameuse photo d'arnaud montebourg a fait
la semaine alors moi j'ai pas très bien
compris quoi si c'est quoi encore une
pub pour le mariage gay
on m'a expliqué que c'est censé
représenter la france qui réussit à une
marinière un mixeur
arnaud montebourg le mannequin des vide
greniers du 11e arrondissement
ok y'a une montre herbelin soi-disant de
luxe sur une montre de luxe avec un nom
de camembert ou de biscottes
comme si les allemands faisait des
voitures haut de gamme avec des prénoms
de concierge espagnol
s'ils voulaient vraiment marquer le coup
ils auraient mieux fait de poser en
costume dior bottines berluti dans un
rafale avec une escalope de foie gras
posé sur la gauche
heureusement que sa copine porte des
lunettes à 15000 euros il y en a au
moins un an pour attraper autre
façon politiquement il ya rien à dire
que je veux dire hollande impérial de
gouvernance héros incandescent charisme
valls unique voulez du gouvernement
alors moi ça suffit le holland bashing
moi je vais pas le critiquer plus ça
passe plus je le trouve sympa quoi pour
une fois qu'il ya un type qui met un peu
de poésie dans la politique quand je le
voyais fait penser à un personnage de
jacques tati faisant du pédalo au milieu
du cap horn
il manque un truc sur le portrait
officiel du président cissé magritte qui
avait fait il aurait écrit ceci n'est
pas un président
et puis et puis jean marc ayrault pareil
quand enfin il a pris son autonomie quoi
qu besoin de ses ministres pour
cafouillé s'est ingénié on peut espère
keaton du texte législatif foutu
d'avancé et le type il vient à la radio
pour dire oh on a fait un texte mais
passera pas
c'est vraiment un humour que le type il
a de la peine à recadrer ses ministres
il annonce une opération pour pacifier
la corse ouais
ben voyante le chef des logis jean marc
qui lancent l'opération tempête du
maquis
résultat deux jours plus tard nouveaux
morts sur l'île à mon avis le corse il
est mort de rire quand en apprenant à
ces héros qui allait le cadre est quoi
alors ça ça ne s'est pas su c'est normal
c'est la tradition en corse par honneur
on a criblé son corps de balles en corse
une mort naturelle c'est jusqu'à trois
balles
entre 4 et 8 c'est un différend
économique au delà de 8 c'est une bavure
de chasse
ça c'est bon quoi au moins et un truc
dans ce gouvernement il ya du désir il
ya du désir najat vallaud-belkacem
ah ouais non
comment résister à son air d'écolière
ingénue qui semblent dissimuler derrière
son pupitre des socquettes blanches à
pompon est sous sa jupe une culotte bio
c'est à dire rien
pour moi elle représente la synthèse
idéale de deux choses a priori
impossible la volupté pédophile sans le
risque de l'âge
puisque
sur la prochaine fois que je la croise
moi j'attaque direct
alors ça se passe bien au cm2
vient chez moi on va faire un atelier
pâte à modeler pardon c'est un
gouvernement qui semble obsédé par le
cul mais sans rien y connaître
franchement ils ont cette idée de
rembourser la pilule des quinze ans il y
avait une mesure beaucoup plus simple et
moins coûteuse encourager la sodomie
non mais
les encourager par là mais la sodomie
c'est quand même un beau geste de mixité
sociale
la volupté du riche la contraception du
pauvre
et plus la gauche est faible évidemment
plus ça aiguise les appétits alors
borloo a décidé de créer lui dit rien
que le sigle moi j'ai pas envie d'y
aller enfin gea côté os ou st lô c'est
plus sexy
mais quand tu vois les parages giscard
simone devait l'emmener en 2012 il
on est en 2012 il convoque les trente
glorieuses face et qui va faire la bande
son du clip de campagne vladimir cosma
un peu de compassion chrétienne même
vous pelletier franchement vous toute
façon si vous avez fait des conneries
fin faut arrêter le rapport merapi
constate que la des séries a sous-estimé
le risque c'est vrai quand on lit le
rapport y avait pas de quoi s'inquiéter
recel d'armes goût pour les scream
frères salafistes visionnage de casser
de l'exécution intérêt prononcé pour les
tribus pakistanaise voyage de six mois
en afghanistan
tu lis le rapport tu dit ce mec c'est
pas un terroriste et un ethnologue
[Applaudissements]
l apple claude lévi-strauss de la cage
d'escalier pas si on lui avait laissé le
temps il aurait pas pondu tristes
tropiques mais facétieux pachtoune
façon qu'on cesse les stigmatisations ça
c'est le grand mot la somatisation
armstrong que le stigmatiser de la
semaine
alors c'est peut-être pas un exemple
pour les jeunes qui font du vélo mais
quel exemple pour les toxicomanes qui
n'en font pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà un homme qui prouve qu'on peut
être toxique eau gagner de l'argent
avoir une vie normale des enfants faire
du sport enfin
franchement à part lors des descentes de
police est quand même rare de voir un
consommateur de crack faire du jogging
c'est moi j'ai vu des toxicos en plus
mauvais état franchement armstrong pour
un drogué tu mets dans une salle de
shoot tu le confond avec le médecin de
garde
sinon à wil et bonne nouvelle de la
semaine kerviel de rembourser 4,9
milliards
by cc facile lui la seule solution c'est
le mariage gay
à part ce mac et avec bernard arnault je
vois pas trop de solution pour lui
et puis des trucs plus ça c'est assez un
peu de respect ça c'est un peu compliqué
à 108 ans décès du doyen des rescapés
d'auschwitz
c'est avec ce genre d'infos que tu te
rends compte que finalement faire du
sport est bouffé bio ça sert à rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui j'ai oublié économiquement la
folie fiscale continue oui maintenant on
va taxer les boissons énergisantes
s'écoule vu la mollesse du gouvernement
c'est dans l'ordre des choses reste plus
qu à défiscaliser la verveine
alors pas mal d'années et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus